pékin la parole est à monsieur alain
marty merci monsieur le président ma
question s'adresse à monsieur le premier
ministre
voici un mois les talibans lancent une
offensive sur la ville de kunduz dans le
nord de l'afghanistan dans la nuit du 3
octobre
l'aviation américaine intervient et des
bombardements touche l'hôpital de
koundouz administré par médecins sans
frontières les forces aériennes qui
interviennent connaissent les
coordonnées gps de l'hôpital
les responsables locaux dès les premiers
bombardements informe kaboul et
washington malgré cela le bâtiment visé
continue à être pris pour cible pendant
45 minutes
le bilan est lourd 12 tués parmi le
personnel soignant dix personnes parmi
les hospitalisées dont trois enfants
brûlés sur le lit d'hôpital à la suite
d'un incendie
les explications du général campbell
commandant des troupes de l'otan sont
pour le moins confuse
il admet néanmoins la nécessité de
revoir les conditions d'engagement le 7
octobre le président obama a présenté
des excuses pour ce tragique accident et
annonce une enquête militaire interne il
est important de marquer notre désaccord
avec la destruction d'un hôpital
c'est un acte inacceptable contraire aux
conventions de genève est contraire à
nos valeurs
msf demande une enquête transparente et
indépendante menée par la commission
denquête international humanitaire
officiellement créée en 1991 pour que la
commission soit saisi il suffit qu'un
des 76 état qui l'a reconnu en fasse la
demande
cette demande a été formalisée monsieur
premier ministre ma question est simple
est-ce que le gouvernement soutient
cette demande d'une enquête indépendante
deuxièmement est ce que le gouvernement
a saisi la commission denquête
international humanitaire
si vous ne l'avez pas fait pour quelles
raisons troisièmement souhaitez vous
demander aux autorités américaines et
afghanes de faciliter cette enquête est
de ne pas l'entraver
je vous remercie
si monsieur marty la parole est à mme
chow secrétaire d'état chargé des
affaires européennes
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
député alain marty mesdames et messieurs
les députés
nous avons comme vous-même était
profondément choqué par le bombardement
d'un hôpital de médecins sans frontières
en afghanistan comme vous l'avez rappelé
le président de la république des états
unis le président des etats-unis barack
obama a présenté ses excuses à cette
organisation non gouvernementale pour un
bombardement qui a causé de nombreuses
victimes à la fois parmi les malades qui
était soigné dans cet hôpital
et parmi les personnels de médecins sans
frontières qui avait été recruté pour
tenir cet hôpital
ce bombardement est manifestement la
résultante d'une erreur dans
l'appréciation des cibles est en effet
une enquête doit être menée pour établir
les responsabilités dans la décision de
mener cette attaque de ne pas
l'interrompre
alors que déjà avait été signalé que
l'hôpital était la cible de ce
bombardement et que effectivement
médecins sans frontières avait notifié à
la vente aux forces de l'otan et aux
forces américaines les coordonnées gps
de ce site sanitaires nous attendons
évidemment les explications qui seront
données par les états unis dont je
rappelle au demeurant que c'est tout de
même un allié à la fois au sein de
l'otan et aujourd'hui sur le plan
international nous demandons donc que
toute la clarté soit faite et cela
montre à quel point il est absolument
nécessaire dans les opérations
militaires internationales de veiller
aux règles d'engagement à la protection
des populations civiles et à ne pas être
associés à des crimes qui peuvent être
des crimes de guerre nous pensons en
particulier que tout doit être fait pour
assurer la protection des organisations
humanitaires de la croix rouge et en
particulier des organisations françaises
et internationales qui viennent au
secours des populations civiles je vous
remercie merci monsieur le ministre
pour la gauche dans l'euro